[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day Los
Angeles edition we are in beautiful
Hollywood California all week
that enemies are tonight we're going to
talk about that we're going to talk
about if Taco Bell is in fact the best
Mexican restaurant in America but first
we want to talk about the NFL in a game
yesterday
Vontae Davis of the Buffalo Bills quit
at halftime they're getting their butts
kicked and he said you know what I'm
done with this I don't want to get
tackled anymore getting tackled hurts
and he walked away so looking at this
group has anyone here ever quit halfway
through something I think I know the job
during lunch who actually regrows why I
waited so lunch because I left my jacket
in the office which was locked and I was
like well we could I get my jacket and
say you have to wait to save the
children people would like that outside
research and I didn't like the way they
had these kids of day it was the kids
were not being saved because if you do
the math on it they had one kid writing
these letters to everybody I was like
that doesn't make any sense Panda
Express after four hours this is so much
worse you quit on the kids half hours
$28.00 you do you got to check oh I
would I check out check out this tweet
from the this is Vontae Davis official
statement so basically you can read the
whole thing but what he said was today
on the field reality hit me fast and
hard
I shouldn't be how life comes out too
fast
with quitting the NFL halfway through I
fully support this because if his heart
is not in it he could die it's not just
reality coming fast and hard at him it's
a grown man that are 400 pounds the
worst I mean he could break his neck he
could die when Chris quits a job halfway
through just some kids go don't get fed
that I supported Vontae Davis because I
have never gotten a chance to be on any
kind of sports team tried out for many
sports teams in high school and was
denied never been accepted once in my
life I also have never I've never quit a
job I once spilled my own urine at a
restaurant where I was working what
happened I was it was a drug test before
we open the restaurant we had to take it
in the restaurant I had my cup of urine
I tripped didn't put your influence
where I still went to work the next day
Wow so you tripping do one of these it
flew on my friend who was in front of me
the restaurant hadn't opened yet so this
was like let's a drug test every
circumstance where a restaurant opened
or not open should say bring your urine
yeah
inside well I I was like oh that's weird
these don't twist on I guess you just
put it on top you know
Vontae Davis natasha is calling you a
coward but Terry Crews does support you
he tweeted his respect so much respect
it's your life freedom is never popular
but oh so necessary blessings to you
Jordan I want to hear from you what have
you ever done anything like this left in
the middle of summer I I mean I quit my
internship at a magazine like in college
but it wasn't like brave or anything I
like went to the I like waited for when
my boss wasn't in that day and I went to
her boss and was and cried Wow
laughs ride and went behind the back of
yeah I thought I would be brave and be
like what she doesn't even talk to me
when I'm in the office but I just cried
I can relate to Vontae Davis because I
like to Irish goodbye from every party I
ever go the other night I was walking
with Chris out of a bar and I was saying
goodbye to everyone and Chris all it was
like next to me did not say goodbye to
anyone and just left is Mexican food
especially Taco Bell and according to a
Harris Poll throw up that next headline
talk about one a poll for America's
favorite Mexican restaurant part of the
reason is because it's only big chain
restaurants like Chipotle and Moe's that
have the name recognition to be able to
compete in a national poll but even with
that I love Taco Bell I'm happy about
this what do we think did they deserve
Taco Bell is better than most Taco Bell
is better than Chipotle Taco Bell oh not
better is not the best Mexican
restaurant but this survey is
because they also voted Krispy Kreme the
best coffee shop and Krispy Kreme is not
a coffee shop so this is clearly Donnie
oh but you understand that they sell
coffee at Krispy donut shop oh do you
think that Shake Shack is a burger joint
or a shake shop because they sell
burgers there in their great damn it
you're right very high and just decided
to pull their friends and somehow this
got picked up on whatever website this
is that little that little rag People
magazine I think like Taco Bell is doing
such innovative stuff with Mexican my
favorite coffee shops voting and
competitions how's that for a segue the
Emmys are on tonight at 8 o'clock
shout out to South Park The Daily Show
and drunk history from Comedy Central
for getting those nominations we love
yet but I want to talk about The Comedy
category it's pretty interesting this
year we got a lot of first-time noms
some people who have been nominated
before but I've never won before I'm
rooting for Barry's personally for ya
yeah what are we doing what do we think
will win what are you
loved barry i also loved marvelous mrs.
Mazal and i also i want them to win
because I want to know how to say it is
it Faizal Maisel when they say it on the
show then we'll know Barry's the best
one as well but it was not funny yeah
well and also Atlanta one of my favorite
shows not feels like a stretch to call
it a comment which one are you from
Barry but I wish the good place was
nominated did it miss good place is
really I think that's why I got the
forest we missed this year right now
that's my bad guys I was supposed to
fill out the form and I just forgot to
put it on I guess write us in yeah it's
not too late we got a couple hours left
we hold for siren where's that fun and
exciting that's what they do this every
time someone signs a movie deal we can't
show it but the Hollywood signs on fire
right now
legally not allowed to share the
Hollywood yeah that's a very interesting
thing some guy owns it mr. Hollywood all
right hey we made something fun here in
Los Angeles check it out right now
[Music]
hi I'm Natasha we're here in Venice
Beach California I'm gonna add some
people some California trivia if they
get it right they get a free taco if
they get it wrong Ryan eats a taco
right in front of them oh no no no no no
tacos baby the California state flag has
one animal on it what is that animal
snake not a snake did you have lunch
today
you didn't so this is probably really
upsetting Brian loves tacos name one of
the two US senators from California
Arnold Schwarzenegger
sorry not a current or ever US senator
even a Brian
how do you feel seeing the taco-eating
in front of you can't do anything about
it I lost but you were a great
competitor
yeah I was great up straight all right
we've got two contestants which means
two tacos are on the line your question
is the California State flag has two
words on it name one of the word freedom
they're incorrect
I think it says bear Ryan do you know
yeah California is this your favorite
thing to do ever mm-hmm Justin how well
do you know California I live John my
life perfect because rains eating for
tacos in the last 10 minutes what is the
capital of California Sacramento sorry I
wasn't done with the question spelled
backwards in five seconds stop it that's
not fair how many tacos do you think
you've eaten in your lifetime
not enough please get this right
Michelle I'm gonna give you a real easy
one because Ryan is getting full how
many professional basketball teams are
there in California
- there's four oh good hot sauce no
that's way too much and we stop
interviewing groups California is
located on what coasts of the United
States
yes sorry I was looking for left that's
not that's subjective
hey your comedian eats a taco that's
great you know this is Ryan's dream job
named the Governor of California Oh
human
I'll give me the first name Jerry
it's not it wrong yum-yum yeah do you
want to be on camera yelling at a dog
Ryan is that the image you want of
yourself
you're making Frank upset I'm sorry
Frank all right and where are you guys
from what the cornea has the ninth
largest economy in the world so how many
inches are in a meter
I'm guessing three thousand no she don't
know we were friends
all right that knock Oh buddy
right
[Music]
are you guys gonna get tacos now Ryan
you okay you okay buddy Ryan you okay
you okay there are three main deserts in
California each of you named me once the
Sonoma ooh
incorrect you got a three tacos Ryan how
you feel Ryan yummy taco I'm a very good
friend I would say maybe Ryan's best
friend Ryan how many tacos are we eating
today Oh Paul for me you want out of the
bit buddy
yeah doing a little bit you know what
we're done you did a good job well we
went to Venice Beach and we learned that
no one knows anything about California
Ryan what's going on with this outfit
like every white dad and that goes on
why for the first there are no rules
here it's a thousand degrees I'm awesome
I'm also sitting in the Sun but I'm not
wearing that
yeah well then you've you've dug real
hot in summer where you're from it's
humid but like we're just sitting in the
Sun I'm gonna set on fire if I take this
hat off I know I look like I'm on Safari
but this is it this is the look all week
baby you look every damn day you're
watching I'm a turn egg you got cut from
Jumanji yeah we don't need that guy
already tired ended the show you can
stop this michael cera auditioning for
knives nigel thornbury I really ended
the show or it is we don't roll the baby
I may turn thanks for watching
sorry and his family didn't come you
look like an got kicked out of Walley
world
[Laughter]
[Music]